mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalkar
a sequence starts with the number one
and each subsequent term is multiplied
by the common ratio a
until the final term of a to the power
of n for n a positive even integer
we're going to define two variables
x is equal to the median of the sequence
and y is equal to a to the power of n
over 2.
which of the following statements is
always true
x is greater than y
x is less than y
x is equal to y or none of the above
this problem is adapted from the 1996
sat exam
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we can start analyzing this problem by
considering specific values
suppose n is equal to four
in that case y is equal to a to the
power of two
what is x equal to
let's consider a specific value like a
is equal to three
we substitute that in calculate that y
is equal to 9
then we calculate the median
the median will be the middle value of
this sequence which is equal to 9 that's
exactly in the middle
therefore x is equal to 9 and x is
exactly equal to y
let's do another example
let's again consider n is equal to 4 so
that y is equal to a squared
now let's consider a is equal to
one-half
when we substitute in we get a
decreasing sequence to calculate the
median we'll put it in ascending order
here we have the median is exactly equal
to the middle value which is 1 over 4
and that's exactly equal to y
therefore again x is equal to y
from these particular examples one might
conclude that x is always equal to y
well this is actually true if a is
positive in that case the sequence is
either increasing or decreasing
and the median will be a to the power of
n over 2 which is exactly equal to y
therefore x is always equal to y if a is
greater than 0.
the official answer to this problem did
say that x is equal to y
however it's an incomplete answer it is
not the correct answer
a 17 year old colin rizzio figured out
the correct answer should be none of the
above and it made big waves across the
media at the time
let's see why none of the above is the
correct answer
we'll again consider that n is equal to
4 so we get y is equal to a squared
now we consider a negative value for a
let's say a is equal to negative 3.
if we substitute that in we get an
alternating sequence
y is equal to 9 what's the median value
what's the middle value of this sequence
to calculate the median we'll arrange
the sequence in ascending order
we can now see the middle value is equal
to 1 and x is equal to 1.
therefore x is less than y
so we'll put this particular case
together with the other case that x was
equal to y for a positive value of a
putting these observations together we
can solve the question
which of the following statements is
always true
well can we say that x is always greater
than y no we can't because sometimes
it's less than y and sometimes it's
equal to y
again we can't say that x is always less
than y because sometimes it's equal to y
and we can't say x is always equal to y
because sometimes it's less than y
therefore all of these are false and the
correct answer is none of the above
the moral of the story is you should not
blindly accept the official answer
it's best to do your own analysis and
mind your decisions
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]
you